um i'm nikki
i'm evan and we stayed yeah for the
summer it was a summer fling
we did it for a year and a half we're
both worried that
we would catch feelings that we would
fighting all
the time yeah so he broke up with me on
g chat what you did i sent him a
termination letter
i demoted you she demoted me dear corey
it is with sincere regret that i must
inform you that you have been officially
demoted to
a guy i used to hook up with dearest
karen nicole
what can i do to re-earn a position
doing many different positions
you approve mom i mean i mean that's a
pretty good rebuttal that's a pretty
good rebuttal
very professional i appreciate it how
long did it take you to get over us
and what did you do to help yourself get
over it
[Laughter]
this dude is um
you know what it is i'm gonna tell you
what it is okay i'll tell you what it is
you haven't even seen it but i'm gonna
tell you what it is this
is just like the sock from the other
video all right the hole in the sucks
this is what it is i'm gonna tell you
why you're cringing like that you
haven't seen it
but this is why when you sit in a
foldable chair
and your butt is so far packed in the
chat
[Laughter]
oh
[ __ ] let's go that's a good one
can't go there no
oh right now i'm getting over it right
now by doing this
how long did it take you to get over us
and what did you do to help yourself get
over it
i can answer that question it was a
month and you dated some other guy
end of story it's supposed to be me you
should drink for them no you should
drink for them
okay so that's why you guys are not
together right there you got a really
upset
it took a month and you were dating
somebody else
what do you miss most about us
yep yeah it goes by
i dare you to take a body shot off of me
to get out of this you have to take two
shots what does that mean
what's a body shot like drink out of
your
belly button
[Music]
she spills it oh
i'm going to do it all right all right
so i'm just going to go in
turn your head to your right no no
you're left
what did your friends and parents think
of me
oh
he said they said why does he sit like
that
[Music]
because because the vulnerable the
foldable chairs like that
or when did you break out at christmas
and then
that's when you get darker
you put one of those chairs out you like
have a seat and you all look be like
um
i don't want to say i'll just
if we were the last two people on earth
when we become lovers
presumably there's no internets
yeah totally yeah i agree that's the
easiest question ever yeah we'll do that
yeah probably yeah i mean not even last
two like like last like
five thousand probably five thousand no
like oh
please don't do i ever bob into your
head when you
please drink that please drink
that i don't want to know either way
thank you curious about
yeah sometimes you know you could call
me
when that happens
[Music]
[Laughter]
all of a sudden he just saw the red seat
part he said that's my home
that's my opening uh call me get him
call me
get him i approve let's go no
it's it's me time but you know
when you say it's me time if you flip
that m it could be
we time
no that's good that'd be weird right i
think so
[Music]
[Laughter]
probably distracted yeah you would just
be like i hate this this is so bad
why are we doing this pop into makes it
seem like
like i'm just thinking of something and
then you popped into my head
yeah like
[Laughter]
where do you see us in the next 10 years
i feel like i see us baby growing apart
that's a sad thing to say do you regret
going out with me
no not a bit that's good to hear yeah
okay god damn she's still down down [ __ ]
down down down
yeah they by the time this was over then
now
yeah i dare you hmm
to kiss me on my mouth
[Laughter]
do i drink two i hate you
oh i would so much rather kiss you on
the mouth and take that shot of whiskey
okay let's do it okay okay all right one
two three go okay
yeah bam all right
hey hey
let's go let's go hey
love to see love is in the air
that was a great video that was awesome
there's a lot of fun people in the chair
man that [ __ ] image is stuck in my
house don't bring that [ __ ] up man
[ __ ] why did you
i told you listen let's just keep it
positive uh the the show
i really enjoyed it you saw it great
it's just [ __ ]
stop i can't stop that
all right man listen great great great
job y'all are great people
deuces [ __ ]
[Laughter]
crazy
[Music]
she used to see my housemate i went on a
date with his best friend
and met him and then nine months later
we started dating
not gonna lie i thought it was
maybe it is about six years ago was it
six years
yeah it's been six years wow not gonna
lie i thought it was christmas again